on the next Rick and Morty don't drop
the truth tortoise also whatever you do
don't look into a side look at Rick now
you're gonna know everything Morty good
jobs I can't go on like this what's the
truth tortoise in my head come on Morty
come with me this Morty is my archive of
all the experiences you've begged me to
remove from your life
I called him Morty's mind blowers and
we'll be doing this instead of
interdimensional cable birdperson you
always stick up for Rick but he doesn't
care about anyone but himself
he doesn't think about the consequences
of anything he does and as a result he
has the power to save or destroy entire
worlds and he is the reason you and I
know each other and the reason I'm alive
at all what's that who's that baby
you've lived quite a life Rick it's a
real shame you're not gonna be around to
see it through
[Music]
you're crying over a Morty no I'm just
allergic to dip shits hey everybody knew
Rick and Morty so I've gotten so many
requests for an evil Morty origin story
video and so many of you believe the
popular theory that he is the original
Morty of c-137 Rick making him see 137
Morty because they never officially
confirmed which Morty are Morty is
they just make him seem like c-137 and
because we only meet them in the pilot
episode we don't really know when their
first adventures were so there's a lot
of backstory that's really mysterious
and I think there's been some evidence
in previous episodes as well as episode
eight where Morty learns the truth about
everything from accidentally staring
into the truth turtle's eyes this spells
out a little bit more of the backstory
pre our Morty in the first episode so if
you are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get everything will
be doing season 3 and season 4 videos
pretty soon too but the important thing
to remember about Rick is that he cares
about Morty that's what we find out
during that evil rick torture scenario
where he's showing him his life time
he's just pulling memories out and you
see a baby Morty but you don't know
which baby Morty it is so I think that a
lot of people jump to the conclusion
that that is in fact the evil Morty
because they believe that the pilot
episode is the very first adventure that
our Morty goes on with Rick meaning that
he's not the original Morty of c-137
Rick which I actually think is wrong I
think that this Morty is our Morty like
the one that we're seeing stare into the
eyes of the truth turtle he's had
adventures with Rick before this first
episode but they've been so traumatic
that he just had the memories for move
so when you're looking at all these
memory vials here there's stuff that
predates episode 1 and because he
actually stares into the eyes of the
truth turtle he gets the whole dose of
the truth not just the memories that
he's had removed so he also probably
learned something about evil Morty's
backstory too and it'll be interesting
to see if he actually retains on to some
of that information or if Rick just
pulls it right back out because the fun
thing about Rick and Morty is is that
during season two like that bird person
clip where Morty's like he doesn't care
about anybody he's slowly coming to that
conclusion but then you get the speeches
from people like bird person who
explained no you
understand what's going on Morty and he
tells him wobble of a dub dub means I am
in great pain so part of the beauty of
c-137 rig is that he's so messed up I
mean it's hilarious but he's really just
trying to protect his family
despite scenes like this where he's at
the morty store making them seem
completely disposable and that only came
after we saw the council try to give him
a voucher for a one free morty where
he's like no no no we don't want morty
to learn that he's completely disposable
so really the lesson there is just to
take everything they tell you about
Rick's backstory with a grain of salt
maybe it's true maybe there's some
falseness in there they've even come
back and said that when he's showing his
origin story to the groffle mites and it
turns out to be completely false that
it's actually not completely false
there's a little bit of truth in there
based on all that it seems like what
happened is is that evil Morty is one of
the original Morty's and just happens to
be smarter the way we've seen some
Dumber versions of Rick like tall Morty
I know there are all kinds of theories
about tall Morty but I think he's just
meant to serve as an example of a Rick
just because there are infinite Rick's
that there are some that are born just
not quite as smart as other rigs so you
then have to assume that there are
Morty's that are smarter than other
Morty's even though Rick keeps telling
him how dumb he is
I know a lot of you are also talking
about that comment that he had at the
end where he says a cocky Morty could
lead to some bad things for everyone
just don't get too big for your loafers
Buster Brown a cocky Morty can lead to
some big problems can be a real bad
thing for everybody oh yeah how's that
I'll explain when you're older in the
way they cut that scene with the evil
Morty reveal definitely implies that
Rick has knowledge of an evil more tea
or other kaki more teas that led to
really bad things but I think he's
speaking mostly in generalities because
he's hopped to so many different
dimensions that he's dealt with examples
of evil Morty before he's the ultimate
example of how bad a Morty can get when
he starts acting like he thinks Rick's
act so like I said Morty completely
misinterprets what rick is like so evil
Morty is someone who's emulating a lot
of the things that Rick's do in a very
sinister way he just burns his way
through many Rick's that was what that
scene was about where's your original
Rick and we know that he's already
burned through one of them because we
saw him abandon evil Rick and we don't
know that that was his first rig that
could have been c-137
but I still feel like what they're
trying to tell us with all these bird
person flashbacks and the idea that Rick
did come back during that 20 year
absence to hold baby Morty from c-137
before he left again
so just because Beth talks about Rick
being gone for most of her childhood
doesn't mean that he didn't pop back in
every once in a while it sounds like you
and my dad have a long history together
wish I could say the same the road your
father and I walk together is soaked
deeply with the blood of both friends
and enemies must be nice I used to have
to draw them into family photos with a
crayon okay so let me get this straight
for the rest of your lives no matter how
much it hurts you no matter how much it
destroys our children's futures we're
gonna do whatever Rick wants whenever he
wants I think the idea that when she was
growing up and when Morty was growing up
he popped in every once in a while and
then would just erase people's memories
when things would happen so even though
our Morty's only supposed to be about 14
years old now there's probably earlier
memories of Rick that he's just had
erased somewhere in this room but
hopefully that explains a little bit
about Morty and Rick's backstory before
the first episode the origin of evil
Morty how he still had to sort of
falling-out with Rick but it doesn't
confirm that evil Morty is c-137 Morty
and I wouldn't be surprised if our Morty
is the way he is big
has these had memories removed maybe he
would also turn into an evil Morty - if
he always knew the truth
maybe that has something to do with
what's going on with evil Morty he's
just a version that has more knowledge
than any other morty of the crazy things
that rick has done and even though
ultimately rick is a good person you
have infinite Rick's so he's seen enough
evil Rick's that has twisted him but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner at garret 94 please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details -
giveaways for the art book that they
just released now all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video
announce a new winner when I post my
episode 8 video tomorrow but be sure and
check it out new episode tonight while
you wait for that you can click here for
my episode 7 video and you can click
here for brand new flash season 4 thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]